as i mentioned we have a very special
guest this hour
she never does interviews like never so
i'm feeling super special right now
she's a fellow texan a teacher a mother
a loving wife and the creator of the
laura bush foundation for america's
libraries
which supports access to books for all
kids across the nation
please welcome former first lady of the
united states laura bush
[Music]
hello it's kelly
hello it's so nice to see you thanks
thanks for having me on
oh my gosh thanks for joining us i'm
very we're honored to have you
and obviously we're very honored uh
because we're going to be honoring
teachers today so
who was the first teacher who had an
impact on you well i had a second grade
teacher that i really
loved i wanted to be just like her her
name was miss
naggy charlie neggy and i stayed her
friend for the whole rest of her life
i got to invite her to the white house
um
there's there you see her right there
and she was really the influence on me
that made me want to teach second grade
wow then she did have an impact um what
was your first
teaching job because i remember my mom's
a teacher and i remember even when she
started student teaching
those were hard days especially middle
school um was really rough
the kids in puberty all of that um but
were you nervous or was it hard
sure i was nervous i thought my very
first year i taught
in dallas at longfellow elementary
which happened to be the school on my
street i could walk down to the
uh school that was there and yes i was
very nervous
and then after that year i thought i
think i need to go
work downtown i'd move to houston the
next year and
i got a job downtown in a brokerage firm
and found out that
nothing is as entertaining as teaching
because with all those little
personalities
in the room there's never a dull moment
there might be some bad moments that
you'd like to skip but in general it's
really very
very fun but what made you want to move
from teaching to being a librarian i
love books is it just your love of
reading
that was it i mean that was my favorite
part of teaching and that was
reading stories to kids working uh
talking about literature
children's literature and so i went back
to graduate school and got a degree in
library science and
worked at a public library in houston
and then worked in school libraries
that's what i was doing in austin when
george and i married
oh my gosh i loved our public library i
support them wholeheartedly right now
it's so hard because they're struggling
a lot of the public libraries but
that is where i got because we were so
poor there we didn't get we didn't have
money to buy books so i'd get all my
books they'd have like tapes
so i'd get all my music they had like a
catalog section for that
i loved our public library um and i just
loved reading my my mom really invested
that me at a young age
but what were some of the first books
that you remember loving as a kid
well of course i loved all the laura
ingalls wild wilder books the little
house on the prairie and the little
house in the big woods and
all those laura you know she was had my
same name and she had brown hair and
um so you get to i got to sort of grow
up with laura
that's amazing my my the book that
changed me because my mom would always
try and get me to read it until a
certain age in middle school i was kind
of like i don't want to read
and and then i read matilda and i
thought it was the most magical thing
ever and i always say from that book i
kind of
i figured out your imagination has no
budget but movies sets do
and so you can create the most magical
places like with books
um and i fell in love with that and the
boxcar children was my thing as well but
um
but you've just realized i remember
bucks yeah oh i love those
um but you've just released a summer
reading list for kids so what are a few
of the books on it
well of course we had to put on a
beverly cleary book we just
lost beverly clary and uh we put on the
mouse and the motorcycle but
i remember when barbara and jenna were
little
barbara would wanted to learn to read so
badly and she would read beverly clary's
book ribsy
about the dog so we have beverly clary
as one of the books on that book list
um but speaking of books i said this was
our biggest giveaway show ever so let's
get to it
as mrs bush knows a school is built on
books um and so does scholastic which
oh my gosh i loved this little magazine
so much it was like the best time of the
year when i was a kid
and it was a one time my mom would let
me shop because we were poor but she was
like i'll invest in the book so
anyway for a hundred years scholastic's
mission has been to serve
teachers so to help teachers transition
back into the classroom and build their
classroom libraries scholastic is
donating five thousand dollars worth of
books to every teacher and our house
seats
wow that's crazy that is great
each oh my god
i i can't tell you how happy i was every
time my mom brought those scholastic
things home i was like which ones can i
get i was like i love that little
magazine so mrs bush i have to ask you
like how did your love of reading in
books influence your work as a first
lady
well i did i started a foundation that
gives books to
school libraries because of course i've
visited schools all over the
country and many schools
have and of course usually in the parts
of town where kids need books the most
need to have books in a library would
have so few
books very few reference materials and
so i started a foundation that gives
books to our money for books to school
libraries so school libraries can build
their collections for their
kids that's that's the lara bush
foundation
absolutely i love how your foundation
provides such opportunity for kids that
would never have that
but since your mother-in-law barbara
bush also had
that job you had an advantage no other
first lady
ever had so did she ever give you any
advice
well i did have a huge advantage i mean
you can imagine having barbara bush for
a mother-in-law
and i do remember when she talked about
what she wanted to do which was also
literacy
she has had started the foundation the
barbara bush foundation for family
literacy
that gives supports family literacy
providers
and i think that was terrific but she
did she really knew
that daughter-in-laws didn't want advice
from their mother-in-laws
but one time she told me she said listen
don't criticize george's speeches she
said that she'd criticized her george's
speech
and he'd come home from week for weeks
afterwards with letters saying it was
the best speech he'd ever given
so i took her advice this is when we
lived in midland texas and george was
running for congress
and which he didn't win and i took her
advice and we were driving in front down
from lubbock to midland driving turning
into our driveway and
george said how was my speech and i said
well
it wasn't that good and he drove into
the garage wall
you know what though we need those
people you need the we don't want yes
people around us
right you want people to keep it real um
well i tried not to
criticize him after that in speeches
um well mrs bush uh we asked dr jill
biden um
and michelle obama the first thing they
want to do post pandemic
uh dr biden wanted to go out for martini
and fries which i loved
um so what have you checked off your
post pandemic to-do list
well i hugged my grandchildren oh yeah
when george and i were
in new york a couple of weeks ago we got
to go by and
see all three of emilia and poppy and a
little baby howl
and they were so wild jumping off the
couches and acting so wild with us that
we decided maybe
we were too old to be grandparents
that's amazing well the good part about
being grandparents you get to give them
back after you play with them
that's right yeah so uh well speaking of
family your husband just released a new
book featuring immigrant paintings and
stories
um when he started painting he wasn't as
good as he is now i've heard so how did
you as a teacher encourage his work
or was this like the speeches and you
just laid low
i lay low
but actually he he's really gotten good
i'm shocked i mean he was not interested
in art at all
the white house has a major collection
of american art of course he
never really looked at it um so i was
very surprised when he took up painting
but
he's gotten to be really good that was
one of his first paintings that's
amazing
but now of course these are the
portraits of immigrants that are at the
bush center
in dallas and i want to invite everybody
come to the bush center and
uh see the paintings there are
immigrants that you know
like henry kissinger or madeleine
albright or than people that you don't
know
that have immigrated to the united
states and it's their paintings their
portraits
and their stories man they're beautiful
i
i have tried so hard to paint i tell you
what i am the worst at it
so well we found this quote of yours and
i love it you said
when you're married to the president of
the united states you don't worry too
much about him leaving his wet towels on
the floor
but in dallas things are different memo
to the ex-presidents
turmoil in east timor is no longer an
excuse
not to pick up your socks
note to self you can do it now so has
has your husband gotten used to picking
up his own socks
no not really
that's awesome okay well we had we had
jenna on this show i love
your daughter by the way she's so fun i
kind of feel like we are separated at
birth every time we hang out
um but she mentioned that the white
house was haunted
um did you ever experience that no we
never
i think barbara and jenna were the ones
that felt like there was that it was
haunted and
pretended like they heard voices and
it's probably just the secret service
talking down the hall in another room
that they heard but
but we didn't think it was haunted we
love living there it's a magnificent
house
and it has a magnificent art collection
which was also fun to have the chance to
live with those
beautiful paintings no it's definitely a
beautiful
house i will say that i've been there a
few times and living there would have
been a little daunting for a kid i think
i think i would have been terrified okay
so i'm not sure if you know this
uh but today is national no dirty dishes
day um so
who washes more dishes in your house i
think i know this answer
you or president you know the age i know
that yeah of course i do
of course i do yep i'm still here just
waiting for you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever